[Music]
this is human rabies introduced by the
bite of a rabid dog these are actual
cases all of the patients were dead
within 12 hours after these pictures
were taken rabies is a virus disease
that affects the central nervous system
where it destroys the vital centers this
youngster could not understand what was
wrong with her did not realize that
death was inevitable in dogs the
symptoms are variable but usually in the
early stages sudden movement or noise
caused exaggerated nervous responses
as the disease progresses paralysis of
the jaw and throat may occur at this
stage the dog is unable to swallow and
saliva drools from his mouth some hours
later the paralysis becomes more general
causing loss of muscular control finally
death occurs due to paralysis of the
vital centers this dog does not drool at
all however the symptoms of rabies are
beginning to show the virus is in the
saliva and the animal is infectious
the dog may show a marked change of
personality and may swallow bits of wood
stones or feathers frequently he will
bite animate or inanimate objects in
furious rabies the dog may run about
aimlessly attacking other animals and
humans frequently causing severe
outbreaks of the disease however the
form shown in this film called dumb
rabies may be equally dangerous because
the characteristic symptoms are not
evident
rabies may be transmitted by infected
foxes domestic cats dogs and other
biting animals although all warm-blooded
animals are susceptible to the disease
because of the close association between
dogs and humans the dog is our chief
concern in considering the rabies
problem this is any American community
lots of youngsters and lots of dogs
certainly no one is thinking about
rabies but rabies is here carried by
this forlorn stray dog from who knows
where already he has bitten a pet dog
this is the beginning of an outbreak of
rabies nothing spectacular nothing
sensational no snarling frenzied animal
but the rabies virus has been introduced
into the everyday life of this community
a few weeks later it begins to show
itself the boy is friendly playful pet
turns mean bites his master and several
neighborhood children within a few weeks
the pet dog dies autopsy and subsequent
laboratory examination prove beyond a
doubt that the cause of death was rabies
there is no choice now but to give each
of the bitten children a long series of
anti-rabies injections most of them will
be protected but some may not
this could have been prevented through a
sound rabies control program what is
wrong with this community I take good
care of my dog he hardly ever goes out
of doors but he can't get rabies rabies
whistle I've raised dogs all my life I
never heard of a case of rabies well I
don't think rabies will ever be much of
a problem here that was the trouble with
the community apathy and ignorance but
after they did have an outbreak of
rabies the whole story changed now the
people ask that something be done to the
local board of health came groups of
citizens to discuss a program to
eliminate rabies from their community
the board appointed a public health
veterinarian to direct the program his
first move was to get pet owners to have
their animals vaccinated base Memorial
Park let's get rid of ready bring your
dog to the community sponsored
vaccination clinic today at 4:00 Robert
thanks Memorial Park
everybody please today let's get rid of
Lee
the response was gratifying pedigreed
dogs and mongrels high bred and low bred
but each one loved by someone who wanted
his dog safe from rabies modern rabies
vaccines caused little discomfort to the
dog but are highly effective giving a
much longer period of immunity than the
older types in preference to the
community sponsored vaccination clinic
many people prefer to have their private
veterinarians vaccinate their pets as
the immunization proceeded another phase
of the program was in action the picking
up of stray dogs a real threat to the
community well trained dog wardens were
given the responsibility of picking up
strays and taking them to the local
animal shelter this was a
well-constructed up-to-date building
where humane treatment was emphasized
and the dogs kept in clean quarters
dog suspected of having rabies were
isolated and kept under observation the
removal of strays and the vaccinations
of pets soon showed definite progress
but there was still one more factor to
consider the woods at the edge of town
offered harborage for foxes which had
been very abundant that year cooperating
with the rabies control program the
state wildlife Commission agreed to
reduce the number of foxes in this area
excessive numbers of foxes in a given
area form an ideal situation for an
explosive outbreak of rabies scientific
reduction of their numbers is good
conservation practice and good rabies
control
so as time went on this community gained
increasing control over its rabies
problem the citizens learn the truth of
the statement that Public Health begins
with the people themselves yes we
learned the hard way but now we
protected our pets from rabies well I
sure was wrong having a broad vaccinated
against rabies is a man's obligation to
his neighbor's well I guess we've all
learned rabies can become a problem in
any community now we're rid of rabies
and it will never get back well that's a
pretty strong statement rabies can
always be reintroduced for instance a
new family moves to town from a
community where rabies is present the
pet dog has been exposed but symptoms
have not begun to show then a few weeks
later he becomes irritable and begins to
wander aimlessly this time the people
know what to do
as later tests prove the new dog was
indeed rabbit in the course of his
wandering he had bitten two pet dogs one
of these had been vaccinated only three
months before he was revaccinated and
confined to his yard for 30 days if no
symptom showed in that time he would be
safe the other bitten dog had not been
vaccinated so he would be held six
months for observation thus a second
outbreak was avoided and this same three
part control procedure vaccination of
all pets keeping stray animals off the
streets and controlling wild animals in
the outskirts of the community this same
pattern of rabies control will succeed
for any community or county or even
state providing it has the wholehearted
backing of a public with a real desire
to stamp out rabies
[Music]